VINCENT SCHEIB: Hi, I'm Vince.
I used to work on some
console games.
Then, I worked on a game engine
called Gamebryo, did
that for about five years.
And now, I work at Google on
the web browser, Chrome.
I'm going to talk to you for
about an hour on the bleeding
edge of open web tech.
So let's define open
web technologies.
The open tech is basically APIs
is that are available for
you as a developer that is
implemented by one or more
browser vendors, or at least
could be implemented by
another browser vendor if only
one browser vendor is
implementing it at this time.
Often, these technologies
go through a
standardization process.
For web technologies, that's
frequently the W3C.
That offers benefits for
gathering feedback in a
central location and going
through a very formal process
of hardening and stabilizing
of specifications.
Sometimes, this technology
is also open source.
It's available for you to look
at the source code and include
in your own projects as well.
There's several benefits of
using open web technology.
Basically, they come down
to being a free
economy or a free market.
Because multiple browser vendors
are implementing a
technology, there's motivation
to compete for implementation
quality and speed to
implement APIs.
That benefits you, the
developer, who wants the
highest quality APIs possible.
In the open environment, it's
also easier for you, as a
developer, to influence that
technology and the progress
that it makes.
And the individual browsers
that are making those
technologies are more keen to
pay attention to actual
application needs, because if
they don't pay attention,
another browser vendor will, and
they'll lose market share.
Open tech also helps
technologies live longer.
You have more trust in the
longevity of a technology when
there are multiple
implementations, when you have
the ability to even implement
it yourself if needed.
So in this presentation, I'm
going to be focusing on the
bleeding edge of open web
tech, specifically
with a lens for games.
Now, a year ago at Game
Developers Conference, I gave
a presentation doing a survey
of all the technology that I
thought was relevant
for games.
And I went through all the
basics and went through a lot
of examples.
A lot has happened in the
last year, and in this
presentation, I'm going to try
to focus on what's happened
recently in about the last six
months, and also focus on the
current discussions and possible
futures for these
technologies.
To do that, I'm going to have
to jump through a lot of
different technologies.
So I've got an overview here
mentioning graphics,
networking, audio, et cetera.
We're just going to bounce
around through all these
technologies.
And at times, it can be
a little bit janky,
but bear with me.
We're going to just cover all
the news that I could find
that I thought was interesting
for game developers.
At the end, I'm going to talk
a little bit about apps,
stores, and browsers.
The takeaways I hope you're
going to have are new
awareness of technologies and
the future direction of those
technologies, an idea of the
current state of the platform,
and I'm going to do that through
some demos of actual
commercial games running
on technologies today.
With this information, you
should be able to go back,
work on current games that
can deploy today.
But some of the technologies I
talk about aren't going to be
ready for shipping a
game stable today.
But they're definitely ready for
you to do R&D work on and
plan for the future, and also to
influence the direction of
the open web platform.
So with all that said, let's
get started with a demo.
This is SKiD Racer.
And let me bring up.
All right, so this game
is currently shipping.
It's available in the
Chrome web store.
It's been implemented
in JavaScript.
It uses WebGL, the
Web Audio API.
And let me just try to race
it along a little bit.
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
So a caveat of all of my demos,
it's a little bit
tricky to demo on the spot.
And I'm not always
the best player.
But I hope you get a sense of,
hey, wow, a 3D game looking
like this running
in JavaScript?
That's awesome.
If you had shown me this three
years ago, it really would
have blown my mind.
It's awesome that web browsers
are becoming a platform so
capable for this level of
quality of games today.
And I'm really excited about the
future of getting higher
and higher quality games
available in the web browser.
So let's get into the meat
of the presentation.
What I'm going to talk about
first is performance.
For myself at least, I always
used to think about the web
platform as a fairly
low-performing platform.
JavaScript was pretty slow.
I didn't think a lot of it.
I was a console game
developer.
It was all about optimized
C and C++, doing assembly
coding, doing shaders,
and things like that.
Well, there's a lot of movement
across all vendors to
improve the quality
of performance.
And let's hit some
of those topics.
One important concept is
going multi-threaded.
Web Workers provides the ability
for JavaScript to run
in parallel.
And a traditional web page is
just one thread of JavaScript
that is modifying the contents
of the page for display.
And it competes with several
other things the browser
itself implements to
display that page.
Web Workers allows you to have
JavaScript code that runs in
parallel on another thread.
Some recent news there is that
Internet Explorer is adding
them into IE10.
So that's great because that'll
bring them to all the
major browsers on the desktop.
In Chrome, there's been recent
improvements as well.
For example, they've been moved
into the same process as
the main thread, lowering
the memory footprint.
Chrome uses multi-processes
for part of its sandboxing
technology, which is why they
were in one per process
previously.
In Web Workers, there is a
method you can call called
postMessage() and this is the
synchronization primitive of
Web Workers.
There is no Mutex or other
synchronization primitive available.
There's really just
message passing.
Previously, passing messages
always meant
copying your data.
Copying the data is fine when
it's small, but when you're
dealing with a game, you might
be trying to, for example,
take your physics simulation and
run it in the background
thread and then push updates to
the main thread for display
through, for example, WebGL.
You might be updating
quite a bit of data.
It could even be a
couple megabytes.
So making a copy of all
that is a poor choice.
postMessage() now includes the
ability to transfer ownership.
So on the background thread,
for example, you can update
and prepare your world state,
and that can be quite large.
You would call postMessage(),
and on that object, you would
lose visibility on the
background thread, and it
would gain visibility
on the main thread.
It would just transfer
the ownership.
Eric Bidelman from Chrome
Dev [? World ?]
did a quick check of, for
example, transferring 32
megabytes between threads.
And on one machine, he saw
an improvement of 300
milliseconds down to
7 milliseconds.
That's almost two orders of
magnitude performance
improvement for transferring
large blocks of data.
So that's pretty cool.
Along the lines of performance,
another thing
game developers have been asking
for is vector support
and matrix support
as first class
citizens of the language.
The good news is this is in
discussion now on the public
effects working group list.
Matrix4x4 looks like it's
going to be the first class
to be implemented into
JavaScript.
And it's just a beginning step
for linear algebra types being
available in JavaScript.
But it's a great start because
as we move forward, I expect
we'll be able to see more and
more types and classes
available, which can lead to
better optimizations in the
JavaScript virtual machines and
easier utility for game
developers.
JavaScript in general
is always improving.
Mozilla has a great phrase, Are
we fast yet? where they've
been tracking the speed of
their performance for
JavaScript.
And they've been making
improvements year over year.
Chrome, when it launched, was
notable for its inclusion of
the V8 engine, which has
excellent performance.
And it's been improving
well over time also.
Some recent news is that
incremental garbage collection
has been introduced in both
Chrome and Firefox.
That reduces the occasional
pauses that garbage collection
would introduce into apps.
In games, that's a really poor
scenario because it causes you
to drop frames or have a
stuttery frame rate.
Now that it's incremental, that
problem has largely been
diminished, and there's more
of just the simple constant
tax of garbage collection
instead of postponing it, and
then having a stuttering frame
rate for your users.
Type inference is also
now available.
Type inference allows for more
aggressive optimizations.
JavaScript is--
when you pass in data
to functions, it
could be of any type.
It could be a string.
It could be a number.
And that's a problem when
you're trying to
optimize that code.
Both Firefox and Chrome are
doing optimizations based on
type inference.
And they are realizing, hey,
this inner loop is really only
running off of numbers.
And specific machine code can be
highly optimized for that.
In Chrome, there's a technology
call Crankshaft
that does this with stochastic
profiling in real-time of
where the hot spots are in your
code and aggressively
optimizing those.
A recent Firefox report
indicated that they had a 2x
improvement in their box 2D
performance over the last
year, which is pretty cool.
It's now about six times
slower than native
hand-optimized C and C++ code.
So JavaScript is definitely
getting faster.
Another component to talk about
in performance is the
use of typed arrays and
how they're spreading.
These were initially introduced
in WebGL.
They've been used for vertex
buffers, textures, et cetera.
You specifically were able to
specify the format of data
that you were placing into these
arrays, which helps with
your code being optimal and
accessing that data.
They're now available
for transferring
objects between threads.
As I mentioned earlier in Web
Workers, typed array's one of
the object types that can be
transferred and have the
ownership transferred.
They're also used in networking
with web sockets.
When you're sending binary data,
you can do it through a
typed array.
XML HTTP request, or XHR, is
also supporting loading data
directly into a typed array.
So when you fetch your assets
from a web server, you often
are doing so with XHR.
And previously, you had to
re-process that data in order
to prepare it for
use with WebGL.
Now you're able to, if you
choose, optimize the
client-side processing by
loading it directly into a
typed array.
And the last thing I want to
mention in performance is
Intel's Rivertrail.
So this is a pretty cool project
that they announced.
It is open source and
available on GitHub.
And they have a demo that you
can try out in Firefox.
Their goal here is to enable you
to take advantage of more
and more CPU power.
They want you to be able to
take your embarrassingly
parallel applications
and implement them
in JavaScript easily.
So they have a concept called
parallel arrays.
And what you can do is implement
a function in
JavaScript that's a
kernel operation.
And you implement that function
in the context of
just a single element in an
array or, for example, a pair.
Say the i-th offset of
both array a and b.
That kernel then composes
a new result
based on those inputs.
And it can do so in parallel.
The framework itself can spread
it out based on the
number of processors on the
machine to take advantage of
all the hardware.
It's pretty cool.
It's probably still a ways off
from actually being considered
into a stable shipping
browser.
But it's nice to see the
research work being done to
bring massively parallel
operations to JavaScript.
So that wraps up performance.
Let's move on to graphics.
In graphics, we're going to
start from the beginning.
How do you get your
content on screen?
Traditionally, you do
this with a timer.
You would update your state of
your web page and hope it's
displayed to the user.
If you want an animation, you
would set a timer and try to
update 10 times a second or
maybe 100 times a second.
The problem is you might be
running ahead of what the
browser can actually display
to the user.
You have no idea.
You're out of control
in this situation.
Request animation frame
understands that the browser
is compositing all the content
of a web page and the browser
UI and displaying
it to the user.
It knows what rate things
can be displayed.
By using this function, you take
your JavaScript code and
provide a callback that the
browser recalls as soon as it
can to display the next frame.
You'll be called once every time
the browser is going to
display content on the page.
So it gives you the ability to
render at 60 Hertz without
doing too much or
too little work.
It has some other benefits
as well.
If the user tabs away--
for example, to check their
email or anything else--
request animation frame will
stop calling your draw calls
on tabs that are not visible.
So that helps you be a better
citizen by not consuming
computing resources that are
going to go to waste.
It does the same thing if you
have a particular element on a
web page and that element
is scrolled out of view.
So if you have a very long page
that has a lot of dynamic
content, that content is only
being rendered and updated
when it's going to be
visible on page.
So now that we've got our cycle
of draws in place, let's
try to show them on screen
and make them
as pretty as possible.
I've got another demo in
fullscreen that, I think,
shows this off well.
Previously, browsers allowed
you to go into
presentation mode.
And you could make the browser
fullscreen and take the whole
web page contents up.
But in this case, we've got a
game that's basically in a
little box.
And what we want instead is, on
the web page, we want the
ability to click a button and
bring a portion of that page
fullscreen.
We don't have to tell the user
how to interact with the
browser's specific user
interface for going
fullscreen.
We can just put the controls
directly into a web page or
into a game and allow transition
into fullscreen.
So very useful, especially for
games where we want to really
take over the entire
monitor display.
And now, I'm going to talk about
WebGL, which is really
the meat of graphics.
There's quite a bit
of news here.
So some recent things, first of
all, if you're not familiar
with WebGL, it's OpenGL
ES brought
to JavaScript bindings.
OpenGL is a long-term graphics
API available on the desktop.
It was fairly large.
And when mobile platforms
started to support 3D, they
wanted to minimize it to just
the recent high-quality
feature set without
any redundancy.
And that became OpenGL ES.
WebGL exposes that
to JavaScript.
So some recent news in WebGL is
that texture compression is
becoming available through
an extension.
And that provides S3TC, or more
commonly known as DXT,
compression formats.
So that's great to know.
In Chrome, we've recently made
it so that errors are
automatically reported to the
console without performing any
special operation for any of
the error checking that we
have to do as just part of
normal security checking,
which is a fair amount of error
checking in OpenGL.
If you want absolutely all error
checking to be done, you
can use a command line switch,
enable GPU debugging, which
will call glGetError after every
call that you make, and
that will help you find
any errors rapidly.
Firefox, I believe, has
always had an option--
although you have to enable
it-- to display errors in
their console.
Some of the upcoming features
in WebGL are the support of
32-bit index buffers.
Currently, they're are only
supporting 16-bit.
Also, an extension to offer
instanced drawing.
And finally, shared resources
across canvases.
So in WebGL, a canvas is the
area of a web page that you
can send your 3D content to.
For games, you're probably going
to have just one canvas.
But it's possible that you might
want to have multiple
view ports interspersed with
other web page content.
If you do that today, you can't
share vertex or texture
data between those canvases.
And so work is underway to
enable you to do that.
That's somewhat interesting.
But where it becomes more
interesting is in the somewhat
longer-term future of WebGL.
At that time, we're hoping to
share resources across Web
Workers as well.
So I mentioned earlier, for
example, performing a physics
update on a background
Web Worker.
When you do that, you'll have
to transfer that data to the
main thread for submission
to WebGL.
But it would be great if,
directly from the background
thread, you could update
resources, send them to the
GPU, and have them ready for
the main thread without
blocking that main thread.
Other things coming a little bit
further down the road are
anisotropic filtering and also
depth textures, which has a
little bit more of a dicey
implementation question,
especially around supporting
DX9, but is solvable.
So because I'm talking
about graphics, it's
great to have demos.
Many of the demos that are
available on the web now are
tech demos.
There's a few commercial games
like the one I showed earlier.
This is just a ship viewer for
EVE, which I think is great
because it ties in WebGL as
utilized in an auxiliary means
for a large and well-known
commercial game.
So they just have a ship viewer,
but it's pretty cool.
You can see these high-quality
assets, fly in, zoom around a
little bit.
And it's nice to see other
games that have been
longstanding for some time
starting to use WebGL in
situations such as this.
One more, cool.
All right, so now, we're going
to switch gears, talk a little
bit about networking.
On the internet, networking has
always been around, right?
But it's always been in a
client-server model, and it's
been more about fetching
resources.
So typically, a web browser
says, hey, server, can you
give me that web page?
Can you give me that image
or that audio file?
For games, we want something
much more rapid
to enable game play.
So Web Sockets is a technology
that supports that.
It's client-server
still, but it's
bi-directional and low latency.
Previously, to support
bi-directional or to allow the
server to push data to a client,
the client had to open
up a connection to the server
and leave it hanging.
It was kind of awkward, and it
definitely didn't solve the
low latency problem.
Web Sockets does, and
it's available to
work with in Chrome.
It's also being unprefixed in
Firefox 11, so it'll be
available for production
games there.
And Internet Explorer 10 is
bringing support as well.
Initially, it supported
just text transfers.
But binary data is
also on board.
And so you can optimize
your bandwidth usage
considerably now.
So if we're talking about
networking, Web Sockets is
only going to solve the
client-server problem.
You also want to solve peer to
peer problems. So to do that,
I need to talk about WebRTC.
But this is a large
project, so let me
start at the beginning.
The goal of WebRTC is to bring
video conferencing
capabilities and technologies
natively into the browser with
APIs so that developers
can use them in any
way they see fit.
So this includes codecs for
audio and video, real-time
encoding and decoding, echo
cancellation, noise reduction
for both the audio and video,
automatic gain control for the
audio, network jitter
management, again for both
audio, video.
And also, because they're peer
to peer connections, it
includes a solution for NAT
and firewall traversal
technology.
So that's a great start.
And basically, you'll be able to
get things like Google Chat
working on your own web page
or game with APIs that are
going to be built directly
into the browser.
However, that's just
video chat.
And while a lot of games are
going to use video, or even
just the audio portion of that,
it's still not what you
really want.
What you really want
is the data API.
So this is currently
under discussion.
The data API's goal is to allow
you to have multiple
channels of application-specific
data
piggybacking on one of these
peer to peer connections.
It can be reliable or
unreliable, and it will allow
you to send strings,
binary blobs,
array buffers, et cetera.
It will also allow your
application to check to see if
that data's being buffered so
you can adjust your send rate
based on the bandwidth
available.
So that's basically
the holy grail for
games and peer to peer.
It's the closest thing we're
likely to get to UDP through
web standards.
It's still in discussion right
now, but the rest of WebRTC
has gotten into technology
preview in at least Chrome and
Opera at this point.
So one portion of WebRTC is
just the audio and video.
And there's a method called
getUserMedia() which allows
you to gain access to that even
if you're not going to
send it over the network.
So I've got a demo I want to
show you for that as well.
Let me launch that up.
So basically, you can say,
hey, is there a camera
attached to this computer?
Let's load it up.
And here, I've got a WebGL
application that has got me.
Hi, me!
How's it going?
And I can watch TV on TV,
which is kind of cool.
This came from learning
three.js.
So it's accessing my webcam
with no plug-ins, just
directly through the
getUserMedia() API.
So very cool, and definitely
appropriate for
certain types of games.
On Chrome right now, it's behind
a media stream flag.
All right, so we've already
started getting off the topic
of networking and talking
about video and audio.
So let's just switch directly
into audio.
Audio has been available in web
browsers for some time.
The early history
is unpleasant.
In HTML5, the audio
tag arrived.
The goal there was to make
including audio on a web page
as simple as including
an image.
You just put a tag
on the web page.
Game developers noticed this tag
for audio and said, hey,
that's great.
Let's try using it.
The problem was it was initially
designed and
implemented in the context of
including a song or maybe a
streaming presentation
onto a web page.
Controls are optional and can
be displayed to the users so
they can seek around and
pause the audio stream.
You can create multiple hidden
audio tags to have a sound
bank in the background
and use that for
sound effects in games.
But this has been fraught
with peril.
A couple months ago there was
a conference call New Game.
They had several presentations,
and I think
every presentation had
complaints about the state of
audio today in the audio tag.
There are definitely some
problems there.
The good news is there's been
significant progress in all
browsers improving the
performance and the quality of
that implementation.
But in the long run, it's still
going to be an overly
limited mechanism to implement
audio in your games.
So there are some other APIs
that are worth talking about.
A while ago, Mozilla presented
the Audio Data API, which took
the audio tag and it built on it
a little bit by offering a
JavaScript source for
that streaming data.
Basically, every time the
audio needed additional
samples, they could be produced
in JavaScript.
This project has been sunset by
Mozilla in favor of another
API, which I'll describe
a little bit later.
But it also suffers from some
problems, in that requiring
JavaScript implementation of all
your audio processing is
pretty heavy-handed when much
of it could be heavily
optimized directly
in the browser.
That's the route of this
API, the Web Audio API.
The Web Audio API is recently
available in Chrome.
It started shipping last fall,
and can be used today in
stable versions of
the browser.
It has ongoing work.
In November, Intel jumped on
board in WebKit and started
doing some additional
optimization.
And recently, in January, we
added support for sourcing
audio channels directly
from audio tags.
The audio tag has a couple of
good properties, including a
streaming capability.
So you don't have to entirely
pre-load your audio data.
So that's recently available
in the Web Audio API.
And there's been a lot of
background or back-end work
and optimization being
done there.
Angry Birds, which was a game
that was ported to HTML5 tech
and runs on Chrome, last year,
it has recently been
transitioned over to
Web Audio API.
So there's that and a few other
examples of production
games using this API.
The API was initially designed
using FMOD, and Wwise, and
Miles, I believe, from the game
industry as inspiration
for a lot of the use cases and
needs that developers would
have. So it's very suitable
API for games.
Moving forward, there are
several things yet to be done
with this API.
It could be tied in more
tightly with WebRTC--
for example, getting access to
your audio stream coming in
from your webcam.
Or let's say you want to plug
your guitar directly into your
computer and then process
that as well.
It's also a question of
multi-channel sound.
Now, that's multifaceted.
Today, you can load surround
sound through an audio tag,
and you can render that out
to your speakers, and
it works all right.
But what you can't do is
separate those channels and
manipulate them independently.
Being able to support
that would be great.
So that's decoding multi-channel
audio, and then
also re-encoding that when
outputting to speaker
configurations.
That would provide the ability
to also do the 3D
specialization that the Web
Audio API offers, but on
multi-channel audio as well.
There's also a scenario
for multi-bus audio.
So consider, for
example, a DJ.
They're playing some music, and
that's going out to the
house speakers.
But they also want to
preview what they
want to queue up next.
So they want both of those
to be, say, in stereo.
And so it's multi-channel, but
it's not all the same music.
It's not all synchronized
together.
That would be great to support
through this API, as well, and
is being discussed.
There's another question about
device discoverability.
So what kinds of speakers are
on this computer, and what
kinds of audio inputs are
available, providing that
through the API somehow.
That, again, is still in early
discussion and is also related
to the device API's
working group.
And finally, allowing parallel
processing of audio.
Right now, if you perform
JavaScript processing using
the Web Audio API, you have to
do it on the main thread.
But it'd be great to offer
something like an
onAudioProcess call that could
be made on a worker thread
instead of on the main thread.
So I've got some demos that are
worth throwing off here.
Let's launch some of those.
There's quite a bit to cover.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is something simple.
[MUSIC - "BLACKBIRD"
BY THE BEATLES]
Let's just show rendering out an
FFT of an audio stream, and
also playing with convolution
providing
pre-recorded reverb plate.
Bring it back to dry.
Bring it up to the
full reverb.
All right, we can also
do multi-track.
So here's a demo that has
several tracks all being
independently visualized and
controlled with sliders.
[MUSIC -  "1901" BY PHOENIX]
We can bring levels
down and up.
And we can solo out channels.
Cool, all right.
And sample accurate scheduling,
very critical for
games, and one of the largest
efficiencies of the audio tag.
Here's a simple tech demo
showing very tight
synchronization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And just along the lines of
synchronization and hopping around--
[MUSIC - "BOHEMIAN RHAPSODY"
BY QUEEN]
--here, we've got a song broken
up into the fundamental
components, just little
short snippets.
And as I mouse over, I can queue
them up in any order
that I feel.
All right, and let's switch
over to synthesizing some
sound in JavaScript.
ByteBeats are a cool little toy,
especially if you're into
demo [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
type things.
You take an equation, you get
an input for time, and you
just output a number.
And we interpret that
directly for audio.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Very cool, and just an example
of what you can do in
JavaScript.
This demo can be live-edited.
All right, so let's move on.
So another thing you
need in audio is--
oh, I'm sorry.
So another API that has been
proposed-- and this is what
Mozilla is currently stating
as their hope for future
implementation--
is the MediaStream
processing API.
This API shares a lot in common
with the previous API.
They're both graft-based APIs
where you configure from
JavaScript a series of nodes
for leveling, reverb,
convolution, et cetera.
They have a very syntactically
different approach here, but
the underlying concept
is quite the same.
It's at early days
for this API.
It'll be interesting to see
how it moves forward.
And for more details,
you really have to
read through the spec.
And if you're an audiophile and
a developer, I definitely
encourage you to get into the
audio working group and
express some opinions about
the pros and cons of those
APIs so that we can start to
hone things down into a
unified API.
One last thing in audio is the
MediaController, a fairly
simplistic API that allows you
to tie multiple sources
together so that they're
synchronized.
Consider having a video
and two audio tracks.
They could be streaming live, or
perhaps one audio track is
already downloaded by you,
but the other sources are
streaming live.
They could be streaming from
multiple sources, say.
You want to make sure that
they all stay in sync and
never get out of sync.
The MediaController allows
you to tie them together.
In the event that one stalls,
it'll hold all of them
together and things like that.
So, small but very useful API.
All right, let's move
on to controls.
The web has a fairly
straightforward keyboard and
mouse control scheme, but it can
handle some improvements.
Personally, I'm working on
the Pointer Lock API.
This is basically Mouse Lock,
and again, probably easiest to
show off with a demo.
You have a mouse cursor on your
computer, and move it
around with your mouse.
But that's kind of frustrating
for games,
especially in first person.
So I move into fullscreen here,
and I try moving around.
But I have to keep dragging
with the mouse.
And I can hit, for example,
the edge of the screen.
Or if I wasn't fullscreen,
I'd fall off an element.
I can disable the
mouse cursor.
So here, my JavaScript
requested it.
I clicked on OK at the
top of the screen.
And now, there's no
more mouse cursor.
I can move around freely the
same way you would in any
first person game.
I can exit and re-enter
that mode.
And because I've already given
it permission, the permission
is remembered, and it's just
the kind of experience that
you want for games.
So, fairly simplistic.
It's great to have it
moving forward.
I've got an implementation in
Chrome that's available behind
a flag for JavaScript.
It's available for shipping
Native Client games right now.
And on the Firefox
browser, there is
work underway as well.
It's available in special builds
that they have also, so
good stuff.
Hey, now that we're talking
about games and controlling
them, let's talk
about gamepads.
So right here I've got an
Xbox 360 controller.
Some games I prefer to
play with a gamepad.
So in this case, that
wasn't previously
available on the internet.
But an API is under way in
Chrome and Firefox again to
offer this support.
So here, I can push buttons on
my gamepad controller and read
them on a web app.
Very cool, very useful, some
games are just going to be
best with gamepads.
Great.
All right, so we're going
to cover a few remaining
miscellaneous items. Page
visibility, I mentioned
request animation frame and how
you can be a good citizen
by using that and allowing the
browser to not call your code
when you're not visible.
That's not necessarily the only
hook that you're going to
have for doing processing
work.
You might be doing other
processing on a timer, or on a
background thread,
for example.
The Page Visibility API gives
you a direct notification that
you can check for, is this
tab visible or not?
Also, IndexDB, this is
one of many local
storage options in HTML5.
For game developers, the File
System API is going to be very
relevant because files and
directories are a very good
way to manage assets.
You can cache them locally,
et cetera.
That is great.
IndexDB has some recent
news, though.
IndexDB is a little bit more
of a database approach.
It does have efficient
searching, but it's not really
structured in a file system.
It does have fairly wide
support, though.
Internet Explorer 10 is
offering support.
Mozilla has support.
They're adding blobs and files
into IndexDB as well.
Basically, it's on all the major
browsers with the one
exception of Safari so far.
It is even, as well, included
on Chrome for Android.
So that's good to have it
available, and it is a very
good option for the broadest
support of sophisticated,
local storage for your game.
All right, so transitioning
out of some of the raw
platform capabilities, I'm
going to talk about some
language options.
Everything I've shown you so
far has all been done with
just straight-up JavaScript
implemented directly.
But that's not the only
option available.
There are two projects,
Emscripten and Mandreel that
are interesting in that
they use LLVM.
Now, LLVM, if you're not aware
of it, is basically a
low-level virtual machine,
which is a misnomer.
It's more of a cross-compiler
or compiler middle-end that
can do optimization work.
It can have multiple front-ends,
for example,
GCC-based, so you can read in
source code from C, C++, C#,
and others, and bring it
into this compiler.
It can do optimization work,
and it can have different
back-ends as well.
So Emscripten and Mandreel
output to
JavaScript as a back-end.
The JavaScript they generate
isn't really human readable.
It's essentially a
byte code format.
That is interesting because it
provides access to large code
bases that are implemented in
these other languages and
bring them over to JavaScript.
It's also interesting because
those other languages have,
perhaps, more strongly typed
scenarios or don't have
concepts of garbage
collection.
When they're implemented through
this technology on the
back-end, you end up
treating large
arrays as memory directly.
And it can significantly reduce
pressure on the garbage
collection system inside
JavaScript virtual machines.
So Emscripten is an open
source project.
But I mentioned Mandreel
because, although it is a
proprietary solution, it has
some really interesting demos
and games that have been
ported onto it.
So I want to show you this one,
GT Racing Motor Academy.
[ENGINES REVVING]
This was initially made
available on iOS, and here is
running in JavaScript with
WebGL, Web Audio API.
It's using the HTML5 storage
options to cache assets.
So if users return to the
application later, they don't
have to have significant
load times.
And it's just great to see the
possibility of bringing such a
large library of high-quality
game content over to the web
platform rapidly,
so very cool.
Another thing that both
Emscripten and Mandreel do is
offer basically library shims
for software packages that
original applications might
have been using.
For example, if you were using
OpenGL ES 1.1 or 2.0 in your
C++ code, when you convert
them using these tools,
they're converted for you
automatically onto WebGL.
All right, so that gets you
from a lot of languages.
There's another project worth
pointing out called PlayN.
PlayN is built on top of
the Google Web Toolkit.
And it allows you to take large
Java applications and
port them onto JavaScript
as well.
PlayN can support multiple
targets, but JavaScript is the
one of interest to
me right now.
Angry Birds is a good example of
a commercial game that has
used this technology.
PlayN includes a little bit
more than just language
conversion.
It does also have a framework
that is utilized and then
ported onto those multiple
targets.
So that being said, those are
the options to convert or
transcode your games
onto JavaScript.
But there's another option
available as well.
There's an open source project
called Native Client.
It is done by Google.
And its goal is to allow you
to take native applications
and deploy them safely and
securely on the web.
Today, when you browse on the
internet, you download
JavaScript code all
the time, and it's
running in your browser.
And you trust that it
can't harm you.
If you just downloaded
executable files onto your
computer, you wouldn't have the
same level of reassurance.
Native Client is a sandboxing
technology that lets you get
very close to that, though.
It downloads code in machine
format and does a very
efficient static analysis to
ensure that it will conform to
the sandboxing rules that
Native Client enforces.
This means that code can be very
high performance because
it can be optimized, for
example, from C++ and run in
machine code without going
through a virtual machine.
So it's been shipping in
Chrome since last fall.
And it supports C, C++,
C#, and others.
It has a lot of games that have
already shipped, or are
shipping soon on it.
Some examples include Bastion,
Mini Ninjas, Moon Breakers,
some MMOs, Pocket Legends and
Star Legends, Cordy, Muffin
Knight, AirMech, et cetera.
Some cool things coming in the
future, Dark Legends, From
Dust, and more.
So I'm going to show you
a demo of AirMech,
which is kind of cool.
All right, so this is basically
an RTS-style game.
I can move units around, drop
them off, get into dog fights.
And because it's AirMech, of
course, I'm also a mech.
I can land and engage
in combat.
[BATTLE SOUNDS]
So Native Client, I
think, is awesome.
It brings really high-quality
games from these other
languages at a very
high performance
onto the web platform.
And it really opens up your
options for what technologies
you're going to use.
As a game developer from the
middleware industry, I was
aware of a large amount of
awesome options that can get
developers producing
the high-quality
games they want faster.
Well, a lot of high-quality
middleware solutions have
signed up for Native
Client as well.
They include Havok, Unity,
FMOD, Wwise, SDL, Bullet
Physics, BlitzTech, and
Ogre, among others,
so very cool stuff.
All right, so just a few more
things to talk about that are
a little bit more
in the future.
Device discovery, I mentioned
in audio it'd be great to
know, hey, what's connected
to this computer?
But from your controls,
it would be, too.
Does this computer have a
touch pad or a mouse?
It's going to change how I want
you to interact with it.
Maybe it's a touch-based
device.
What's the general performance
characteristic of this machine?
Am I on a phone, or a tablet, a
netbook, a high-end laptop,
a workstation, or an
awesome gaming rig?
I will send different assets
down from the server based on
the general performance
of this platform.
These bring challenges, though,
for privacy of users.
If you're not familiar with the
fingerprinting concept,
it's something we have to
be concerned about.
When a user browses the internet
with a web browser,
they expect a certain level
of being anonymous.
And the more information a web
page can just pull about a
user, the more of a fingerprint
they can build up
and uniquely identify that user,
which is not desired.
Another thing we could use
on the platform is better
time-handling.
So examples include, right now,
you can call newDate, and
you can get the time, but only
up to one millisecond.
So one millisecond is pretty
granular when you're dealing
with a game trying to
run at about 16
milliseconds per frame.
Chrome has a command line flag,
EnableBenchmarking, that
allows you to get microseconds
and could be great, especially
in the profiling nature
of your game.
The other issue with time that
we have is when time stamps
are applied and the latency
related to that.
So for example, in Chrome, when
a button pressed on a
gamepad or when the mouse is
moved, those events are
eventually dispatched to
you via Webkit code.
And the time stamp given to
those events is the time stamp
that we got to dispatching
them in WebKit, but not
necessarily when the operating
system actually informed us at
the browser level.
So there can be latency there
that is made even worse-- for
example, if we're waiting with
requestAnimationFrame before
we're delivering
certain events.
So it would be good to mark the
actual time on events with
the closest value we can
get to the time that
they actually happened.
And I work on Pointer Lock.
There's some other kinds of
lock that would be great.
For example, Keyboard
Lock is a good one.
In a first-person shooter, if
I want to crouch and walk
forward, I'm probably going to
press Control-W instinctively.
The bad news is, in a lot of
browsers, that's going to
close the current tab.
And that's not what I wanted
to have happen.
Another thing we could
do is Orientation
Lock on a mobile phone.
If I want a game that is using
accelerometers, I want to be
moving it left and right, I
don't want it to reflow
between portrait mode and
landscape mode just because
I'm changing the orientation.
I want to lock that down
and not have it change.
All right, so let's wrap up
a little bit with a quick
discussion about apps
and stores.
Chrome has been offering an
application store for a little
while now, inspired by the
success of a lot of the mobile
platforms where users are
getting very familiar with the
concept of an app, giving the
app a certain amount of
permission, and using that for
discovery and replayability.
This is coming to other
browsers as well.
Windows 8 has announced that
they're going to have a store,
and it's going to host
HTML content.
So that's pretty cool.
Mozilla also has announced an
app marketplace, and they have
another concept they've
announced called WebRT.
The WebRT is for Web Run Time,
and the goal there is to allow
applications to get as close
as possible to having a
native-like feel.
They should have nice icons that
look just like any other
icon, and they should have more
availability to APIs that
are native on the system that
they're running on.
All right, we're going to
transition over to just a
quick summary of the
state of browsers.
Desktop share right now is
really dominated by the top
three of Internet Explorer,
Chrome, and Firefox.
And on the mobile space, still
really just three strong
leaders, Opera, Android,
and Safari.
A little bit of mobile
news, Firefox has a
beta version available.
And Chrome recently announced
a beta version available on
Android as well.
So very cool, worth checking
those out and
seeing how they perform.
They bring a lot of HTML5 and a
lot of these standards that
I've been talking about onto
the mobile platform.
Also, IE10, Internet Explorer
has been doing great things in
catching up to HTML5.
Some other recent news, I
already mentioned IndexDB, Web
Workers and Web Sockets.
They also will be bringing CSS3
3D transformations and
also animations.
So, good to see that
there as well.
So let's wrap up.
I really hope that you saw some
tech that inspired you,
and that if you have any
problems or any concerns about
where we're going in the
future, that you will
participate.
The easiest way for you to do
that is to come to the W3C
games group.
This group doesn't perform any
standardization work in itself.
However, it's a meeting point
for everyone with the common
interest of making sure that the
open web platform supports
games as well as it can.
And they understand the context
and other working
groups where standards actually
are being developed.
So come there.
Communicate with people.
Let us know your needs, and we
can get you into the right
direction for communicating
with the people developing
specifications as we move
the platform forward.
And with that, I'll say
thank you very much.
There are notes from this
presentation available at the
link I have here.
So all of the demos that I
showed, the command line
switches that I mentioned, they
can all be found in the
presentation notes.
Thank you very much.